do you know this author brian christian
is that someone you've ever heard of
that sounds familiar he he's a guy
who competed in the what is it called
the loebner competition
yeah the turing test thing so
and i'll just tell you the story but i
think it's directly related to the last
thing you said about where we're we're
starting in the same place
uh he competed
in this in this competition but not he
didn't enter a program that was supposed
to try to uh pass the turing test
the turing test you know there's three
people there's the judge there's the
program and then there's there's a
someone who's a human the way they do it
and the judge has got to figure out what
by asking questions which is the
computer and which is the human so
little known fact there's two prizes in
that competition there's the most human
computer prize
that's the computer that wins the most
and then there's the most human human
rise
and he competed for the most human human
props
and he wanted he kept one winning it and
and so he he tried to think about
what it is that um
you have to be able to do in order to
convince judges that you're human
instead of a computer and that's an
interesting question i think
um and what he came to this my takeaway
from his version of this story
is that it is true that computers are
winning these contests more and more
you know as technology progresses but
there's two possible explanations for
that
one is that the computers are becoming
more human
and the other is that the humans are
becoming more like computers
and he says actually
the more
we live our lives in this world where in
this sort of technological world where
we have to moderate our behavior so that
it's readable
by
something that's effectively you know a
computer
the more we become like that and he says
it happens even when you're
uh not interacting with a computer he
says have you ever been to the you know
on the phone with the call
you know center
and they're going through their script
and that's what they've got to do
they've got to go through their script
because that's how they keep their job
and they ask you this question you've
got to answer it
and it and it's as if you're no longer
interacting with a person even though
it's a person
because they've so given up everything
that's involved normally with being able
to
make judgments and decisions and act in
situations and take responsibility and
so i think that's that's the other side
of it it it it is true that technology
is amazing and can solve huge ranges of
problems
and and do fantastic things but it's
also true
that we're changing ourselves in
response to it and the one thing i'm
worried about is that we're changing
ourselves in such a way that the
norms for what we're aiming at are being
changed
to move in the direction of this sort of
efficiently not in an optimized way
solving a problem and move away from
this other kind of thing that we were
calling alive and aliveness or or
significance
you